quarante six oeuvres pour autant de
regards depuis trois ans les adhérents
d'art gravure saint quentin pour ça la
guerre alors guerre c'est le ressenti de
chacun c'est le vécu c'est l'émotion
c'est faire ressurgir le passé c'est
eux-mêmes j'allais dire un sujet
d'actualité c'est à dire vraiment
aborder quelque chose de très douloureux
quelquefois de pénibles le titre
impression porte bien justement son nom
puisque elle fait référence impression
faire référence à l'atelier de gravure
nous imprimons nous passons sous la
presse et impressions ce sont les
sentiments les émotions des craver
devant la thématique de la guerre est
déjà présenté il ya un an et demi
l'exposition est sans cesse remaniée par
les vingt-deux artistes parfois inspirés
de souvenirs de famille une vingtaine de
nouvelles oeuvres a enrichi la
collection les craver se sont rencontrés
avec les écrits de mérédith le dez qui
était présenté par les itinéraires
poétique et nous avons créé cette
exposition grâce à ses poèmes qu'elle a
pu nous fournir et nous lire même de
l'horreur des tranchées à l'assaut en
pression de guerre lance la saison
culturelle guyot courtoise très marquée
par le 100e anniversaire de l'armistice
ce premier trimestre nous avons voulu
les marais avec la thématique du
centenaire et surtout derrière un gros
projet qui a été monté sur le centenaire
pour finir en ce centenaire
en 2018 avec les scolaires elle
linogravure aquatinte pointe sèche
les adhérents ont choisi de représenter
toutes les techniques de la gravure
un travail long et minutieux à l'image
d'un sujet sensible